come on get the [ __ ] out of here man no
no seriously i'm gonna tell you a story
like
you know daniel cormier dc and stuff
like that i got a job
at this club and this is true story and
i used to be
the name of the club it's called rambe
nightclub right right and i used to be
the guy that said that
it's in colorado springs it's on the t
honey street that's where the train is
yeah yeah and all the olympic athletes
come at night and the military and stuff
like that
and after that one day i was the guy who
picked up the bottles the cup i was the
buzzboy right
but you know i come from a from a
different place and uh
and a big fight broke down and a lot of
the guys with the olympic training
center
big wrestler big guy stuff like that you
know i did i broke the fight i did what
i have to do
and the owner saw that and the owner
said you know what
you know you're not a busboy anymore
you're going to become a bouncer
and uh but check this out in two months
i become the headbands of the club
daniel cormier
henry henry's coaches they used to come
to the club ali please can you let us in
in the club
and i was the head bouncer at this club
for like four years oh man [ __ ]
i i was the head bouncer you remember
that [ __ ]
oh yeah absolutely uh and i used to take
care of all these guys when they come to
the club and stuff like that
but i become from a busboy to a head
bouncer like in three months
well this this is what it was too with
ali man like he became so notorious
for being a bouncer and he was like the
meanest bouncer he used to
pop people he said prop the head
but let's back then back then i changed
i i changed a lot of my ways
because you know it used to be like come
in this military guys come
so angry and understand there's control
and they come and they want to fight and
and and i was it was a little bit crazy
and um and after that
you know the bounce on things is like i
think did it for three four years and
i become a fighter and uh after that i
and one of the things uh side job i used
to have
i used to live at the olympic training
center right and this is a crazy story
in new york they used to have the fubu
the nautica from canal street
all the knock-off stuff like fake stuff
and a friend of mine
i was living on the olympic training
center with all the olympic athlete
but on sunday i used to open back in my
truck and i have like watches
football cd dvds everything
and that was my side hustle and i used
to make money
you know what i'm saying you know what i
say you know i used to make 3 000
a week back then compliment hustler yes
but i was training you know try in the
olympics and i was
a bouncer and i was selling dvds but i
used to go all by the you know black
barber shops you know
and they used i used to go with the
bucks what's up i got what you need
and everybody showed me a lot of in
colorado springs and denver
shout out to all these people and um and
i always like to work you know because
he's just a little world traveler huh
probably not because i had i had like 20
people in egypt
i have my mother my sister people i i
had to take care of them i know
they have no income they can't even eat
like sometime
when i was young i couldn't i i slept to
do with no food
because we like eight people we lived in
a two two bedroom apartment
my mother was sick my father was older
the economy is bad and we live we live
in islam you know we live in islam
but islam in egypt is very different
it's not bad it's it's
it's very religious like very
conservative but b was very poor
and i come here really to kind of change
that life and my life and it worked out
well for me and i'm grateful